tonight we're talking about
moving in with a girlfriend never
covered this before I've kind of alluded
to this uh from time to time in
different uh shows just just just sort
of chopping up the idea right at the end
of the day
look
I've lived with two chicks in my life
okay I've I did it in my 20s
20s was
how do I how do I break it down
it was done okay it was it was it was a
conventional
she didn't have a car I had to drive to
her it was inconvenient
I was kind of poor at the time I don't
know if I was poor but I was
I didn't have bucks Deluxe let's just
put it that way
um
I don't know how old was I 24
like 24ish maybe maybe 25 I don't know
let's just call it mid-20s
and you know it's it's those for four
words that I always use complicate sorry
complicate life justify why
that's what guys do
right
oh
I don't feel like driving to her she
lives 20 minutes away
it'd be probably better if we live
together we could split the costs
more access to intimacy companionship
blah blah blah blah blah right
complicate life justify why
I was presented with the idea
of what's the point I was doing some
mentoring I was a mentee you know for a
change
um I like to put myself in that position
from time to time and
I was talking about something he was
asking me some leading questions and he
was like well what's the point like
what's the point of this like what is
the point and it's like what is the
point
why don't we ask ourselves these
questions more often what is the point
like why are we doing this what is the
point of this where is this going where
is this going to take me is it aligned
with my goals I think more importantly
does it allow me to become
my best self my mental point of origin
is this aligned with the lifestyle that
an unplugged Alpha would live right
anyway back to the 24 year old dork that
I was about 24ish
so moving the girl
stupid move
she had a crazy ex-boyfriend kind of
tracking her
in tow
um
and pretty much everything that a lot of
guys complained about you know I went
through a kind of kind of a funny
experiment I um
I posed the question and I try to pose
these questions to
solicit balanced feedback you know
because if you don't balance your
questioning you're going to get you know
if you're like hey guys why does it suck
living with women you're going to get a
lot of negative feedback so the question
I posed on my two Facebook sorry my two
YouTube channels on Facebook and on
Twitter which delivered over 450
comments some of them were quite thought
provoking men for those of you that are
living with a girlfriend or have done so
in the past what were the pros and cons
okay
the vast majority of guys had pros and
cons listed there was probably two if I
recall that said it was all upside and
they would definitely do it again but
the vast majority said there was too
many downsides for them to entertain it
again so I'm going to be getting into
some of those downsides with you
some of them in my experience myself
again the first time I was in my 22nd
time is when I got married I was married
for
four years almost four years well yeah I
mean it was a separation period but
living in the same house for four years
that shouldn't really count because like
the last
you know like the separation period the
untying the knot period it's it's just a
[ __ ] nightmare so it's not even worth
commenting on that because that's kind
of a skewed opinion but
um a lot of the stuff that happened also
happened you know my 20s and you're
going to get some of the some of the
feedback here in the uh in the comments
I'm gonna just throw them up on the
screen so you guys can follow along with
me
um I'm gonna be taking some call-ins
tonight so if you guys want to uh ask
some questions or chime in with your
experience
uh I'll post a link there later on the
live chat on the YouTube channel
um uh you know right here done it three
times learned but not wrecked
um again you know what's the point like
why am I doing this I think that if you
do it for the wrong reasons like to try
to save a couple bucks
I mean really
make more money
um take on a cool roommate like a dude a
friend your brother
um I've lived with friends I've lived
with both of my brothers in fact
um live with two chicks and I can tell
you it's a lot more fun
um and freeing
if you want to save money to take on a
roommate that you know it's a friend or
even you know your brother and uh and
family
um moving a woman in
to save a little bit of money or to have
access to intimacy which generally
doesn't last over a long period of time
um doesn't really work out you know I
had this conversation with my um
family lawyer we get together like I
don't know once every year or so grab
some lunch grab some dinner
he's a good guy you know save my hind
and
I don't know the second or third time we
got together I said to him something
like you know
because he lives on one end of the city
in Toronto and is
he always seems to find women that live
on the other end of the city
because he kind of works in the middle
of the city or more towards like one end
of the city where the chicks are that
he's dating
so he ends up sort of like commuting
across the city back and forth because
he's doing some work in the city and
he's working from home then he you know
sort of dates and he's like you know
I've kind of resigned myself to the fact
that I'm just going to be a lifelong
bachelor I'm not going to live with a
chick and I was asking him mine is like
there's no real upside to it there's a
lot of downside a lot of legal
consequences there's three main three
main actually four main things if I can
put it that way that I can talk about
which are the main points I'll get into
those towards the end I kind of want to
go through some of the talking points
that a lot of people
um dropped in the comments and sort of
break it down for you
um let's go and start throwing some of
these up here on the screen for us shall
we let's go present sure screen
window and tabs and by the way if you
want to like be able to chime in on
stuff like this definitely make sure
that you're um
subscribe to the channel because the
community tab is where I sort of post
some of these solicitation feedback
polls you might have a hard time reading
it especially if you're on mobile so
I'll just read it out
um so this guy Joe says and my situation
Pros or more intimate time homemade
meals laundry done by the way
I categorize all the pros and the cons
and the pros that popped up almost over
and over again were sex
cooking cleaning
and companionship those were the main
ones beyond that the guys with frame
talked about a lot more which I'm going
to discuss when I get into my four main
points
homemade meals laundry done Etc cons
more time spent watching TV you're gonna
find that you're gonna spend a lot more
time sitting around watching series and
shows it was her home the power Dynamic
now look you never want to move into a
chick's house
if you're gonna do it if look the
unplugged Alpha would not move into a
chick's house okay that's what a plugged
in beta would do you move into her space
she has the frame she controls
everything
um she's gonna set certain terms and
conditions of that living Arrangement
because her house like why wouldn't she
says the boss girl strong independent
women they've been told for decades now
you're strong you're independent uh you
don't need no man you need a man like a
fish needs a bicycle so if you think
that you're gonna move into her house
and you're going to have some degree of
autonomy or say and stuff it generally
speaking as a workout that way
especially with all the feedback that I
look through here on these 450 comment
posts
um was it her which he says was a No-No
you know at the end of it so at least
he's honest about that uh not enough
time apart so things get on people's
nerves and expected help with projects
like you're married yeah I mean look you
move into her house you will be expected
to take on her projects for sure 100
um also the ability to keep tabs on me
so my infatuation with Hobbies were
scrutinized constantly that was another
thing that popped up a lot is guys felt
like
um they lose the ability to maintain
their interests and their Hobbies
because women I mean like women today
are told again strong independent so
they inadvertently try to run a guy
which is kind of part of the [ __ ]
testing system and again it's going to
tie into the four points that I want to
make abundantly clear in this and why
such a bad idea generally speaking like
again it all boils down to like what's
the point like why are you doing this
hey guys I really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out